[Music]
hello I'm wiki bear what's your name
Conan O'Brien
Conan Christopher O'Brien American talk
show host who once made an uncredited
cameo appearance in an episode of How I
Met Your Mother
yeah that's that's the kind of an
unknown fact I'm surprised you knew that
I can answer any question you have i'm
ricki bear okay all right here's a
question what children's character has a
cat named custard and a horse named
honey pie checking now the answer is
strawberry shortcake who actually
started out as a greeting card
illustration in 1977 years oh I didn't
know that that's very interesting you
know what's even sweeter than strawberry
shortcake the Boston molasses disaster
of 1919 when an exploding storage tank
costs two million gallons of sweet
sticky molasses to flood the streets and
kill more than 20 people and their
horses giddyup
yes I am aware that that did happen that
was a terrible tragedy but I don't think
kids want to hear about that many people
tried to flee but became ensnared in the
molasses and drowned
yeah huh I don't think that something
kids want to hear about imagine gasping
for air only to have your lungs fill up
with thick sugary syrup yum yum no not
yummy what a sweet sweet death no nuts
no okay let's change the subject Wicky
bear okay to something really nice and
happy who wrote the famous children's
book good night moon Margaret wise Brown
wrote good night moon in 1947 in this
classic bedtime story a little bunny
says good night to everything he sees in
his bedroom yeah okay that is absolutely
right my kids love that book Conan you
know who didn't have a good night the
late R&B singer Johnny Ace who Beck in
1954 accidentally shot himself in the
face with his own gun KaBlam e okay I
didn't know about that no I did what a
witness said Johnny was drunk and
playing with his pistol his last words
were guns not loaded see but the only
thing Johnny friends saw were his brains
exiting his skull I'm Ricky okay no no
no I don't want to hear that's not a
good song I've heard of an ace in the
hole but this was a real hole in the egg
oh no
no that's wordplay deal with it okay I
don't have living with you bear look we
really need to find a subject that's
more suitable for children and I think
I've got just the one what well
respected actor and star of films like
The Notebook used to be part of the
Mickey Mouse Club that's easy
Ryan Gosling in just a few years he went
from Disney cutie-pie that handsome
Hollywood heartthrob swoon okay
absolutely correct Thank You wiki bear
and speaking of throbbing hearts did you
know the ancient Aztecs performed human
sacrifices
by ripping out the still-beating hearts
of their victims aye Caramba okay yeah
again let's not talk about that that's
something during the recon secretion of
their Great Pyramid in 1487 up to 80,000
people were sacrificed in just four days
talk about a can-do spirit hats off and
hearts out - that that's good we're good
we'll get beer bad all those human
sacrifices couldn't save their
civilization from smallpox so remember
kids nothing you do matters because God
isn't listening morality is a prison and
life is inherently
[Applause]
you